desde la creación misma del estado de
Israel en 1948 la fuerte relación del
eje Washington tel aviv se ha mantenido
inalterable desde los años 70 Estados
Unidos ha intentado sin éxito usar su
influencia en Israel Para calmar los
ánimos en una convulsa región marcada
por atentados y bombardeos hasta 1978
Israel y Egipto habían Librado cuatro
grandes guerras la última La denominada
guerra de los 6 días en la que Israel
había tomado el control de la Península
del Sinaí
sin embargo el 17 de septiembre de 1978
tras 12 días de negociación bajo la
observación de Estados Unidos ambos
países lograron Los acuerdos de Camp
débil el pacto ayudó a impulsar la paz
entre los bandos constantemente en
conflicto
tras la caída de la unión soviética y el
fin de un mundo Bipolar Estados Unidos
emergió como única potencia
estabilizadora en la región el 13 de
septiembre de 1993 este apretón de manos
llevaría Esperanza un enquistado
conflicto entre Israel y Palestina
Isaac rabin y yasel arafat con la
mediación del gobierno de Bill Clinton
firmaron los acuerdos de oslo en los que
el líder palestinó renunciaba al
terrorismo y se comprometía a reconocer
la existencia del Estado hebreo Israel
por su parte reconoció a la organización
para la liberación Palestina como
representante del pueblo palestino tras
la firma de los acuerdos rabín sería
asesinado por un extremista judío en un
acto público
en 1998 un nuevo intento para lograr la
paz establece un actor de la política
actual de Israel sería el protagonista
Benjamin netanyahu y yasela arafat se
reunieron en Maryland y firmaron el
llamado memorando de White River un
acuerdo en el que entre otras cosas
Israel se comprometía a devolver parte
del territorio ocupado en cisjordania y
la olp a controlar a los grupos
terroristas como jamás y la yihad
islámica sin embargo Y ante numerosos
intentos de mediación Estados Unidos no
ha logrado calmar los ánimos en una zona
convulsa sobre todo porque su papel como
actor neutral es puesto en duda
justamente porque en años recientes El
antecesor de Joe biden se demostró
abiertamente Pro israelí e incluso a
pesar de la condena internacional llegó
a reconocer a Jerusalén como la capital
israelí